alec castonguay michels et augé sami
aoun spécialiste du moyen-orient vous
connaissez bien à l'antenne de rdi arts
du canada régulièrement bonsoir
messieurs si vous le voulez bien un
petit extrait du président landais on
vient tout de suite après monsieur le
président du congrès sur le président du
sénat sur le premier ministre mesdames
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mais là messieurs les parlementaires
la france est en guerre les actes commis
vendredi soir à paris et près du stade
de france sont des actes de guerre alors
il a répété ce qu'il avait dit le soir
même et de façon beaucoup plus solennel
devant le congrès c'est-à-dire
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat réunis
à la castonguay vraiment une déclaration
de guerre il veut aller au conseil de
sécurité
avoir une résolution et tenter ces
mots-là d'éliminer l'état islamique
ouais en fait on a l'impression que
depuis maintenant quoi un an et demi
deux ans depuis que le groupe armé
islamique rende de l'importance que tout
le monde veut combattre le groom armures
armes état islamique mais c'est un peu
subordonné à toutes sortes toutes sortes
d'autres impératifs géopolitique dans la
région avec la france veut combattre le
groupe armé islamique mais voudrait
aussi que bachar el-assad le dictateur
syrien quitte même chose pour les états
unis la russie veut combattre le groupe
armé islamique mais voudrait que bachar
el assad reste d'ailleurs l'iran est
aussi de cette position là la turquie
veut combattre le groupe armé islamique
mais n'est pas très heureuse que les
kurdes aide les états unis et le canada
entre autres à combattre le groupe armé
islamique dont on aimerait bien aussi
que les kurdes soient un peu moins
présent dans la région bref tout le
monde des circonstances géopolitique qui
fait en sorte qu' il faut vraiment de
plan de campagne et pas vraiment de
grandes orientations de cohérence dans
la coalition internationale contre le
groupe armé italien qu'on a l'impression
que c'est comme une espèce de
courtepointes où tout le monde ses
intérêts puis en font tous un peu pour
combattre le groupe armé islamique mais
pas jusqu'au bout parce que d'autres
impératifs géopolitique leur lien peut
confronter à la réalité faut que tout le
monde s'entendait à poutine et obama se
sont rencontrés pour la première fois en
tête à tête depuis les verts
l'ukraine ça montre à quel point on est
peut-être prêt à passer à une autre
étape
ce que c'est le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu est ce que tu te plantes campagne
plus cohérent de la coalition
internationale
mais va devoir on va devoir passer à un
autre niveau la part c'est clairement
c'est un échec ce qui se passe la balle
et michel c'est bon on était ensemble à
paris évidemment compte tenu du choc la
réponse devait être de cette nature en
tout cas imprégné dans l'imaginaire des
français que la france 2 se laisseraient
pas faire mais entre le dire
effectivement être efficace sur ce
terrain miné une autre chose dit autre
chose vous savez ça fait quelque chose
comme un acquis à des frappes aériennes
avec l'aviation des états unis ce qui
n'est pas rien avec la france avec
d'autres pays dont le canada et la
plupart des experts militaires vont vous
dire ça n'a rien changé sur le terrain à
la fin
les frappes aériennes peuvent nuire à
l'état islamique peuvent causer des
problèmes mais c'est pas ça qui va
régler la situation à si on dit on va
aller au conseil de sécurité on va à
régler le code du gouverment état
islamique une fois pour toutes il va
falloir envoyer des soldats sur le sol
monsieur obama aujourd'hui encore a dit
évidemment il ya des pas question le
canada le ferai pas non plus puis la
france le ferai pas de re non plus alors
vous savez les frappes aériennes c'est
joli mais pour l'instant ça relève plus
des relations publiques que d'efficacité
lui que militaire sami aoun pour en
régler cette question puis le mot et
grands régler l'année pour tenter de
régler il ya il faudrait donner une
perspective politique pour ces pays la
syrie et l'irak tenter d'apaiser cette
guerre sunnite-chiite bref c'est d'une
complexité inouïe
certainement mais il semble que les
rencontres à vienne commence à donner
fruits peut-être un certain brouillon on
sait pas s'il sera concrétisé mais en
bref c'est un gouvernement de transition
une durée de 18 mois a été fixé mais qui
est toujours sous un débat est ce que
les saoudiens veulent accepter ce 18
mois où ils le veulent à trois mois les
iraniens insistent que le président
assad devrait être éligible pour europe
et encore une fois la présidence mais la
rentrée de russie sur la scène donne un
peu plus de sérieux
il y a une certaine complicité qu'on est
capable pour l'instant de bien la
mesurer entre monsieur poutine et
monsieur obama et sur ce point il semble
l'état islamique est dans une situation
de crise
ils sont en train de perdre quelques
territoires dans les dernières heures
ils ont perdu à peu près de 100 villages
et hameaux ils ont perdu le sinjar
quelques parties de ramadi
alors il semble qu'il y a un peu plus de
sérieux accompagné avec une vision
politique comme sortie de crise mais il
faut l'observer
mais sam est un honnête vous d'accord
aussi que ce un soldat sur le terrain ça
sera difficile de de fer l'autre pas est
ce que les rues sont prêts à s'enliser
ils ont connu eux aussi d enlisement on
pense à l'afghanistan bien sûr qu'elle
l'autre quel est l'autre étape selon
vous à vrai dire les trois puissances
concernées la russie la france et les
états unis sont toujours sur le
traumatisme des échecs de leurs
interventions et déploiement terrestre
c'est pourquoi la meilleure alternative
c'est de renforcer et ce qui se fait
maintenant il y a une force kurde qui a
été de bien entraîné il semble elle
travaille bien avec un appui de
commandos et logistique ils soient des
britanniques ou des américains
il y a une force à l'arbre qui se
prépare et pour la première fois la
russie reconnaît qu'il y a de l'armée
libre syrienne
elle a un rôle à jouer alors ça pourrait
donner une porte de sortie mais rien
n'est sûr
donc vous voyez quand même samedi en une
une lumière là au bout du tunnel vous
voyez une possibilité d' apaiser un peu
d'abord en syrie que le plan russe
finalement puisse fonctionner après les
attentats de paris
cela révèle bien il y à un échec de la
politique de monsieur obama de dire que
je veut confiner ce conflit c'est pas
mon conflit c'est pas ma guerre mais en
même temps il n'a pas pu empêcher des
débordements sur un allié qui est très
important qui est la france
alors il y a
gensse de travailler et d'accélérer mais
aussi après le dossier nucléaire qui a
été conclu avec l'iran sans qu'il soit
maintenant ratifié au disons un solide
et dans le béton mais ça donne une
nouvelle page pour les américains parce
qu'ils n'ont plus besoin maintenant
d'endiguer l'iran ils ont besoin
maintenant plus de concrétiser des
accords mutuels entre leurs propres
alliés l'algérie l'arabie saoudite et
l'iran alec et michel c justin trudeau
qui garde le cap qui a dit aujourd'hui
malgré un discours la plus belliqueux en
tout cas plus agressive des grandes
puissances le canada se retire comme
prévu des bombardements un mot là-dessus
alec rapidement michel va coûter le
canada fait 2,3 pour cent des frappes de
la coalition internationale en irak et
en syrie donc on est pas un joueur
majeur du tout c'est vraiment les états
unis qui mènent ce front là ils ont fait
78 % des frappes donc que le canada se
retire la plupart des spécialistes à qui
j'ai parlé d écouter on peut être utile
au canada dans un autre rôle militaire
là-bas ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
évidemment quitter la coalition
internationale justin trudeau a été
assez clair là dessus en disant on va
rester engagés maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire et là le problème c'est
une question de livrer de timing ce côté
de justin trudeau se dit qu'on a déjà
promis de retirer les chasseurs
canadiens de mettre fin à la mission de
bombardement
on n'a pas encore expliqué qu'elle
volait on allait développer de la
mission internationale là bas qu'elle
volet militaire on allait contribuer
beaucoup tu parles des forces locales
ont parlé des kurdes tout à tout à
l'heure de l'armée irakienne où l'armée
syrienne libre qui sont sur le terrain
qui doivent prendre en charge ces combos
là mais elles doivent être appuyées ce
qu'on leur donne du mentorat de la
formation des armes des équipements
cisco clair le canada ce monologue peut
jouer un rôle important il le fait en
afghanistan former l'armée afghane donc
une expertise canadienne à aller
chercher la bosse certainement si le
canada veut jouer un rôle mais on n'a
pas vraiment d'idée si c'est dans cette
direction là qu'on va aller puis jusqu'à
quel point et michel en fait
diplomatiquement les gens ont dû écouter
monsieur trudeau en a très bien mais
comme le dialecte
c'est tellement minime la part des
avions canadiens qu'ils feront pas une
grande histoire public avec ça c'est
juste le discours qui est un contresens
oui elles discutent d'un contresens il
ya la perception qu'on abandonne la
coalition quand même parce que
à l'écart et zola le canada dit ok on
fait juste 2 % des frappes ça vaut pas
la peine d'y rester mais en même temps
on a dit on veut rester militairement
impliqués dans cette coalition loeb on
leur dit pas ok qu'est ce que vous allez
faire vous le canada alors pour
entraîner des gens pourraient trouver
des armes on préfère c'est aux pauvres
on sait toujours pas ce qu'on va faire
et si ce combat faire sera pas plus
dangereux pour des canadiens que ce
qu'on était des gens très faim vous
savez entraîné des coupes sur le terrain
est peut-être plus de militaires
canadiens qui vont se faire dessus de
cette façon là que deux pilotes de cf 18
alors il faut que le gouvernement
canadien pour qu'il soit pris au sérieux
dans cette affaire le dise nous avons
nos avions mais nous allons faire ceci
puis la partie mais nous allons faire
ceci est par contre les jeux vous
entende les trois sur la question des
réfugiés qui a pris une autre
perspective depuis et samedis depuis
qu'on a trouvé ce passeport syrien piste
d'ailleurs c'était stratégiquement il
avait le passeport i
il le savait ce qu'il faisait c'était
volontaire pour créer encore des
désordres dans ces évacuations de syrien
sami aoun est ce que ça change la donne
façon importante selon vous il faut pas
certainement minimisé les craintes au
niveau populaire même au niveau des
élites mais ce qu'il faut comprendre
aussi
c'est une autre donne et si les réfugiés
qui arrivent au canada sont inscrits
dans le système pour l'heure pour la
plupart ils sont écrits mais si vous me
passez l'expression je m'excuse essais
il y a une bonne sélection et ce n'est
pas comme il se s'impose sur le
continent européen
ici on a le temps d'aller me scrute in
est un peu plus et c'est pas nécessaire
de se mettre une date
impossible qu'ils aient la fin de
l'année on peut commencer à les inscrire
à l'esprit tinée et par après le visa
pourrait être livré quelques mois par
appeler 30 secondes michel 30 secondes à
l'unc là dessus écoutez le problème de
monsieur trudeau la demande du
gouvernement va des brevets de la
société civile pour que ça marche
d'amener 25 mille réfugiés dans un
premier temps il faut que la société
civile en bas qu'aujourd'hui le msci
world
monsieur tories le maire de toronto mme
sirois le premier à saskatchewan jeu
labeaume le maire de québec et jusqu'à
un certain point
monsieur monsieur coderre ont débuté son
concours ces affaires là ça peut arriver
un peu plus tard il ya des craintes
légitimes
il va falloir que le gouvernement
explique ce qu'il fait de côte du comté
sécurité
et puis explique à ses partenaires des
villes sont des partenaires que comment
ça va se passer
il n'y a pas de date fatidique l'avant
cette affaire le noël n'est pas de la
mule alec jetons gouvernement pris aux
dirigeants de garder la tête froide puis
d'expliquer aux gens d'abord que
effectivement un processus de validation
de sécurité qui est fait comme
l'expliqué sami aoun s'est pas des gens
le qui arrive soudainement crise est
plus difficile de donner réfugié au
canada que devenait comme touristes au
canada où on a la liberté de mouvement
il ya des vérifications de sécurité qui
sont en fait il faut savoir où les gens
vont arriver ils vont l'aider on livre
des places donc et tout un processus
autour du processus de réfugiés qui
existent pas même par exemple qu on est
touriste ou même lorsqu'on est résident
canadien faut se rappeler que martin
couture ou losail bibeau était des gens
qui avaient grandi ici au canada
ceux qui ont fait les attentes à paris
la vaste majorité des ressortissants
européens qui avait une liberté de
mouvement donc le danger vient pas
nécessairement des réfugiés surtout que
le processus de sécurité existent le
problème c'est que la crainte des
janvier de la précipitation qu'on a
l'impression que la mine date artificiel
à la venue des réfugiés qu'on sera pas
capable de faire ce processus là des
couettes mans c'est au gouvernement
d'expliquer concrètement pourquoi on est
capable d'y arriver il faut avoir un
délai plus long bain à voir del un peu
plus long il faut garder la tête froide
long terme de sécurité n'y a pas plus de
danger dame me réfugier ici que de
laisser entrer un tourisme merci
beaucoup monsieur on va évidemment en
reparler abondamment cours des prochains
jours merci d'avoir été là ce soir avoir
voix